I couldn't
[Music]
that's a clip from the new world war 1
drama in 1917 one of the films praised
by critics as among the best of the year
this holiday weekend is a great time to
catch some of the releases that you may
have missed that goes for many of us at
this table here to tell us about some of
the other great films of 2019 film
reviewer Eric Davis managing editor of
fandango.com happy holidays welcome all
of these many of these start right there
critics are saying best war films and
Saving Private I would agree
you know it's cliche to say that it's a
film that will leave you on the edge of
your seat the whole time but like
legitimately this film you will be on
the edge of your seat the entire time
for two reasons its story about these
two soldiers who are tasked with a
seemingly impossible mission during
World War one to go into enemy territory
it's bold it takes a lot of risks and
also the way it was filmed this one
continuous shot if you remember the film
Birdman which won Best Picture similar
device so you are so immersed in the
movie and I think that's what makes it
an experience that you absolutely have
to see in the big screen uncut gems and
Adam Sandler is getting so much praise
right now different for him very what a
lot of people love it's very different
for Adam Sandler but then again when you
see him play this guy Howard who's a
diamond dealer
he's a wheeler and dealer he's a sports
betting addict you can't imagine anyone
but Adam Sandler playing this role I
think he deserves the Oscar nomination
if the Academy is watching give it to
the Sandman please I frame Kevin Garnett
with Kevin Garnett and the weekend
playing himself as well but just just
what I love it's a masterclass in
tension it's a film that will make you
feel uncomfortable in all the best ways
well in all the best ways well that's
high praise the film parasite out of
South Korea lots of buzz about this
movie possibly winning an Oscar for Best
Foreign Film do you think why do you
think it's capturing audiences I think
well it's relatable you know everybody
has always looked at an affluent family
and said I would like to taste a little
bit about what your life is but also
it's a lot of things it's a comedy a
drama a thriller a horror movie it's
about families it's romantic at times
you know it's a movie that gives you
everything a lot of different ways to
experience it and it
fantastic not only will it win Best
Foreign Language it may even steal Best
Picture Wow yes the captured audiences
yep but certainly critics critics love
parasite there was so much build-up to
once upon a time in Hollywood Quentin
Tarantino's latest with Leonardo
DiCaprio and Brad Pitt you liked it I
thought it lived up to the hype did you
think it I did I loved it and you know
it's also a film that the farther away
you get from it the more it sticks with
you I felt and it's also the kind of
film that I think when it's on cable
you're gonna get sucked right into it
even if you don't like watching it it's
got Brad and leo so you love looking at
it you know and it's beautiful this is
the movie Quentin Tarantino was born to
make he's it's a love letter to old
Hollywood and I think it does that in
space the one that I love the Irishman
and I will admit I just watched it
yesterday I was like I'm gonna do it I'm
in a sit down did not feel long to me I
know people are saying it did I love
this this is the best of them this may
be your best picture front runner right
now as well Martin Scorsese nice kind of
capper to that quasi trilogy of mobs or
Goodfellas and Casino and now the
Irishman this one a book more reflexive
it's about looking back at your life and
the weight of a life you know it's not
as sexy and flashy as those other mob
movies and I think it speaks to an older
generation like my father just turned 80
loves this film he's watching it more
what does that say about me my my kids
loved Avengers my daughter loves iron
man hates Thanos the critics those seem
to like endgame right how they wrapped
it what's the highest-grossing movie
right of all time at this point there
was a lot going on when I'm watching it
did you like anything I loved endgame I
loved it as a pairing with Avengers
infinity war 2 the one-two punch you
know what Marvel Studios has done in the
last 10 years we've never seen a
storytelling on this scale ever in the
history of moviemaking and so I think
it's just really commendable that they
were able to actually stick this landing
plus it's got time travel back to the
future I'm a huge fan nerd of that movie
and I like the way they use it and they
had all of these 20 some-odd films to go
back to with that plot so I think they
did a really good job so moving on to
the horror movie us which I admit I did
not see because it looks so scary of
course this is by Jordan Peele
out which I did see and loved do you
think that he topped himself with us I
think it's the horror movie of the year
for sure and I think Jordan peel is
probably my the most interesting
filmmaker right now because he's telling
original stories that are not only crazy
and creepy and scary but also thought
provoking and they fuel conversation you
walk out of these films and you're
scared but you're also talking about
race and class and privilege and I think
that's so interesting in the horror
genre and we need more of it and so if
you haven't seen it also Lapita danyoung
go Academy Academy watch out give her
some love I think she's great
murder mystery it's got Daniel Craig and
then you've got this high-tech CG
ability now that we don't often see and
that's with knives out a few dozen go
and see this one knives out as a film
that I'm recommending to a lot of people
because you're going with their family
and they're like everybody likes
something different this film kind of
like clue I think the murder mystery
genre is gonna be making a comeback
right now I think we're gonna see more
of them great ensemble great audience
films so like see this one in the
theater because everyone around you is
gonna be laughing a lot of twists and
turns just fantastic writing from Ryan
Johnson and and and good for Ryan
Johnson with everything that's been
happening good for JJ Abrams by the way
because I think a rise of Skywalker is
is a fantastic finally your favorite
movie of the year yes the biggest little
farm yes why this is also my favorite
documentary of the year you know it's
about this couple who leave their jobs
in the big city to build a farm and what
starts out as this day-to-day of like
how do you actually build a farm they
didn't know what they were doing it
turns into this super powerful film
about you know the family we make the
family we lose the dreams we chase the
risks we take it's got cute animals and
ugly animals it's about the relationship
they have with each other it's about
life and sustaining life because we
could keep going for a long time but we
can't because we have to take a break
you